I feel I feel like it's cool to have
like one weird kind of like passion and
hobby that you just like I don't know I
I just don't know how and I wish I knew
the mechanics of the brain of how the
Joy works there like how that's what I
want to know how did you see oh it's
like I've seen this train leave the
station every time just make you happy
well yeah but I want to know but those
but those same guys are probably looking
at us you know [__] ourselves to the
chainsaw man traveling being like what's
there to get excited yeah maybe they
think like going out drinking that's
something I understand that did you did
you never go through a train phrase when
you were like a kid yeah I did no
what everyone loves trains as a kid are
you kidding I had like I had like I love
training I had like a I had like a PC
game that my uncle bought me and it just
like I had Pokemon right you guys had
Pokemon yeah yeah how the [__] could
trains come this is no this is before
Pokemon this is before like I had just
gotten like memory like image permanence
or like yeah whatever I was like two or
three yeah how the [__] you remember
anything from that no way you remember
two or three year old memories I
remember my my Dad or Mom had
was like a train like shinkansen
Simulator game yeah that came with like
a periphery of like the controls for the
train and I remember playing that as
like a two or three year old being like
I'm gonna be a train conductor some of
my earliest memories are trains I don't
know why I like I don't know why but
like had like man's greatest invention
okay okay here actually yeah what are
some of like your earliest memories like
you can remember what's like the first
memory I've ever formed I have this
memory my mum loves to bring it up to
people okay um I think we were playing
one time me and my brother were playing
with like a wooden train set very like
old style thing
um and I don't know what happened but
there was this like there was a you were
into trains I was playing with trains
what do you mean bro everyone you were
just given trains but I was not into
them I was not like mother but you
remember you're a member only because my
mum kept bringing this up for the rest
of my life
um there was you know they had like a
tunnel a wooden tunnel that would go
over the train track
sugoi the train disappeared yeah and
then it came back out whoa it's like an
isaka yeah and I think my older brother
had knocked my train over yeah so my
response was to just grab this wooden
tunnel and just slam him in the head
my mum just thought oh my God this what
is wrong with this kid he's so violent
so that was how I got into Doom
that's when I didn't uh that's when I
went past my train face yeah yeah I
skipped the training phase went to my
violence yeah and then also another core
memory I have from my young days I think
I was very very young I think I've told
the story on trash days I might have
um we have one of those punching bags
and I told the story I think I have
right it's a punching bag filled with
like water or sand at the bottom oh yes
yes and it came back and smacked you in
the face no
I was punching it as a kid yeah and I
was punching it and I was like ah yeah
yeah punching it goes back up yeah yeah
yeah and I'm I'm laughing on my mum
screams it turned out my thumb had been
all the way backwards from me punching
it I think I told the story I think you
told the story and I just had this core
memory of me looking at my hand and
going like
like a home alone [__] skit uh I
can't remember how I got back what's
your earliest memory well I think I've
already said my earliest memory on trash
case which is getting stung in the eye
by a bee oh yeah uh that that was a cool
memory and I'll never forget the pain of
that yeah that's just that's just trauma
but aside from that like some core
memories uh that are like the earliest
memory are literally to do with trains
it's it was so such a simple joy because
there would be there'll be a train
crossing yes it is very interesting
isn't it
yeah that would be like a train crossing
on the on the drive home from like my
restaurant to like my house and I think
my dad would purposely like I think
before I had like real image permanence
I'm pretty sure
I'm pretty sure my dad like drive around
in circles because it just like I
because I just have this core memory of
like being on the crossing and it's
already for some reason I was always at
the front of the crossing and my dad's
like train coming train and then I it's
almost like my neurons were just forming
because every time I saw a train I would
go train Terrain see it disappear and
then just be like I can't remember what
happened afterwards like the Train the
like all my core memory is just seeing a
train appear seeing it disappear then I
don't remember what came next you know
but I remember this happening so many
[__] times when I was a kid so it's
almost like just like seeing a train as
a kid just fired up neurons in my brains
you know this is how I gained image like
a part of Grant's mind being in his 30s
now just every time he sees the train
just in his head he's just like train
yeah
maybe some people just never grew out of
that you know maybe maybe that's the
train or tacos yeah yeah that's it they
are that kid where at the age of three
they're going trained yeah at the age of
30 they're going strange it's like that
monkey with like the neuron activation
like slime that's what happens when they
see train just like neuron is activating
so we've got to have that thing
everyone's gotta have a thing
what do you mean gotta have a thing
everyone's gonna have a thing like a
thing they like yeah of course because
it's got a hobby right yeah yeah and
some people's uh trains yeah you know
another cool memory I have I I remember
the first time I saw a rainbow actually
that's that's a I don't know why that
was a double rainbow all the way I
remember the exact point I saw my first
rainbow and that was I think happened
right after I saw a train
it was a train with a rainbow on top
yeah I think things set on trains are
inherently cool I think so something
cool about being on a train there is
yeah something I don't know as a kid
there's something just fascinating about
trains and like [__] ambulances and I
I know for a fact at least for me
because like where I grew up we had no
[__] trains whatsoever our closest
train station was like a 30 to 35 minute
drive away right so just the concept of
trains to me just in my local area was
just unheard of yeah so I think that's
why as a kid I got so into trains
because there was that disparity between
being in Australia not ever going on a
single [__] train so going to Japan
where every day you are on a train yeah
so like having a childhood like that for
me just made me be like yeah trains are
sick
exit on the right side will open hell
say it again yeah please did you have
like fire engines uh fire trucks as a
kid just the engine so where the [__] is
this episode
it's like diapers
yeah
helicopters
actually though I don't know I'm just
trying I guess I'm trying to
psychoanalyze myself be like why the
[__] did so many kids I know including
me just like fire trucks if you like
fire trucks yeah 90 probably you buy
so my experience with a fire truck was
when we were I think like first or
second grade we had like a school
Excursion when we went to like a fire
department yeah to learn about like fire
safety and she's like I'm pretty sure
most schools go through this year but
that was the first time like I had seen
a fire truck and they were like you can
hold the hose if you want and I was like
okay
[Applause]
is there anything [__] cooler maybe
helicopter I will say hey yes
helicopter okay I remember I remember my
sister when she was like four years old
for a school presentation she was like
what do you want to be when you grow up
it's just like I want to be a fire truck
not a fire fighter no because it was in
Japanese and like firefighter is sure
[__] and fire truck is sure more
sharp so she accidentally said I want to
be a fire truck and we all thought like
you [__] idiot maybe she's one of the
Optimus Prime
I want to be that whatever that is sure
the all spark uh I I um have you noticed
that in Japan uh people like the fire
trucks and ambulances are way too polite
in America I feel like they're like
balls to the wall get the [__] out of
here it's your fault except in the UK I
feel like people are way too slow to get
out of the way here for them
yeah everyone's very cautious I would
say so I guess that's everything and we
don't want anymore well I yeah because I
see sometimes how slow some of these
like ambulances and fire trucks are like
you know cutting through red lights and
I'm like is that really is there really
an emergency happening or did you just
want to like get home quickly like I
think it's an emergency Jerry yeah
a lot of times they're going slower than
regular cars on a green light so I'm
like are you like in a hurry at all or
like is this building just like gone at
this point now and you just like come
into the after cleanup like what's
what's going on I feel like you should
be in a little bit more of a hurry
especially ambulances oh my God yeah
they feel so slow it's so slow
would not want to be in the middle of
nowhere for ambulance I mean I I feel
bad whenever when I lived in Thailand
and it was like gridlocked traffic and
then I'd hear the ambulance and I'd be
like
a rest in peace
like I'm sitting here in traffic and
like people are trying their best to
make way for this ambulance but there is
I mean there are there are already like
four lanes in this road and there are
five Lanes of cars in this road there is
no space for the cars to move I think
it'd just be quicker for the paramedics
to run over you know
honestly it would definitely be quicker
so cars are moving out the way but it's
it's like it's it is still snail's pace
yeah I've seen fire trucks try to get
through traffic in Bangkok as well that
is that is ashes uh bulldozers on the
front of them
you're moving you don't have a choice I
feel like they'd have a better chance
just hiring an army of like motorcycles
with like buckets of water and one fire
engine to drive through like Bangkok
traffic
deploy the helicopter if your car got
bulldozed out of the way
everyone would move I mean suddenly they
wouldn't have a choice they'd stop
tetrising cars in the street they'd be
like guys uh parking here oh the
L-shaped car oh